hey everybody it's your boy psychobabble
coming to you with actually some light
for once yeah I decided to actually put
a light on my face so you can actually
see what's going on for a longest time
this channel has been very like you know
like whatever you know it's time for me
to wisen up like now my fans are
demanding like more polite like so I
guess we're just gonna do some
professionalism now we'll start with
this question right here I hate them man
burnout yeah I see Vernon has already
affected her face thank you guys sure uh
is that the quest was that a defender of
faith find the damaged shrines okay wait
let me check where is it leading me
suggest a level-10 uh you know let's
just follow it see what happens no
go faster little one go faster man well
my horse is going crazy it's actually
like pretty tough driving this guy you
know the only qualms with this game is
what what the hell is this like GPS
thing like needs the road like if I were
to cut through this path it just goes
like haywire it goes crazy it makes me
like go backwards I get onto a path and
then it goes again like oh watch out of
my way okay this is good this is good
okay I should be getting close to them
right yeah I'm like halfway there okay
I'll see what happens we'll see what
happens oh yeah see wait what the hell
and everyone's like spitting at me I
think I'm almost there it said if any
other faith defender the faith man I
have like you skull things all over me
this is to this quest is too hard they
say no no I pan see I thought I'm just
like lifting up stuff don't vote or
something okay okay now I say what the
hell is that a dragon Cal Cal Cal
Wow oh yeah yeah really hurt can you cut
that out
someone who's calling me ouch ouch this
guy's about to die
well is he freaking running yeah he's
almost dead he's almost dead just kelp
just californ oh my son no I Jesus I
didn't not like what I saw I did not
like what I saw at all you know like
okay I definitely got it I definitely
got a minute ain't that one Jack MAMP
okay one more try no more on where's my
treasure ouch not tell me what to do
and okay I'm kind of far from the next
one but oh well Myra says trying this
best she's pretty tired though they
should just give infants damn and that's
kind of knowing oh whoa what what the
hell brah
holy cannoli can I think stay away from
me and what was that coming towards me
because I really just talk I don't got
time for that
oh man he's getting close he is getting
close Oh
frickin Hegel's house snap
I think it like tries to find out if
you're on a path or not well I'm off a
path sound should be sleek me straight
there well what's going on here well I'm
just here to lift this up here's my
chances they're definitely way to claim
is that next thing dumb for now there's
always at a slice
oh crap
how dude this guy is like yes
stupid bond case see how fast I glitter
you can't stop me yeah I can't step out
out hatch this guy's almost dad about to
get frickin chopped up oh snap
he's almost dad yeah yeah okay I got a
meditate I gotta meditate that's in the
morning okay I did it defender of the
faith well thanks for watching y'all
thank you